[Música]
todos los camiones full 2 3 4 1
desde hace varios meses miles de
haitianos han sido expulsados de
República Dominicana en estos camiones
en octubre 22.000 fueron devueltos a
Haití según las cifras de las
autoridades de Santo Domingo el
presidente de República Dominicana Se
comprometió a enviar a los haitianos
ilegales al otro lado de la frontera en
Haití las organizaciones denuncian estas
repatriaciones y detenciones arbitrarias
con tintes racistas tal es el caso de
Gar el grupo de ayuda a los repatriados
y refugiados en el que sanguine trabaja
como responsable de cabildeo actualmente
las situaciones extremadamente
complicada para los migrantes haitianos
porque en república se siguen violando
sus derechos son maltratados llegan a
sus casas por la noche y se los llevan
sin tener en cuenta su condición su
situación sin saber si están en
situación Regular o no
[Música]
la gente de la inmigración son tan
semófobos son tan racistas lleva a uno
Aunque tiene documentos Mira yo tengo mi
documento mucha gente aquí tiene sus
documentos
su objetivo no es perseguir a los
migrantes haitianos en situación
irregular sino perseguirá todos los
haitianos que se encuentran en suelo
dominicano además si uno es negro y
tiene el pelo encrespado lo identifican
como haitiano
[Música]
incluso hay dominicanos entre los grupos
de haitianos repatriados la embajada
estadounidense no ha publicado
dominicana alertado sobre estas
operaciones policiales que habrían
tenido repercusiones para los turistas
Los viajeros han denunciado haber sido
retrasados sometidos a interrogatorios
por el color de su piel los detenidos
son mantenidos en centros superpoblados
sin posibilidad de imputar su detención
en noviembre la ONU también había pedido
el cese de estas expulsiones forzadas
las autoridades dominicanas rechazan las
acusaciones de racismo pero asumen su
política migratoria que incluso quieren
reforzar de la haba haitiano se está
haciendo difícil ayudar a todos los
repatriados según nuestro observador
realmente no tenemos los medios para
acompañar a los migrantes pero con lo
poco que tenemos hospedamos a los que
tienen dificultades para volver a casa y
les damos comida y ropa porque a veces
llegan en pijama
no se les permite recoger su equipaje
Antes de que los encierren en la cárcel
por eso llegan a Haití sin sus
documentos sin sus pertenencias
[Música]
y es esta razón en general la que empuja
estos repatriados a volver a República
Dominicana porque dejan atrás años de
inversión años de ahorro para evitar
nuevos cruces de su frontera República
Dominicana está construyendo un muro
desde el mes de febrero en total en 2022
más de 100.000 haitianos fueron
expulsados a pesar de la situación
humanitaria y de seguridad en su país
donde más de 150 bandas infringen la ley
[Música]
estas imágenes no son de Qatar donde se
Está celebrando el mundial sino de
kerala este estado del sureste de la
India que está completamente enganchado
al fútbol y desde hace un mes hay mucho
movimiento vamos Argentina
Brasil Inglaterra Portugal España y
Alemania en kerala hay muchos clubes de
hinchas oficiales aprobados por el
gobierno trufer
es el presidente del club de hinchas de
la selección francesa desde el año 2014
actualmente se encuentra en Qatar con
otros 300 hinchas indios de la selección
francesa para seguir sus partidos
el deporte más popular en la India es el
Cricket Pero hay partes de la India
donde el fútbol también es muy popular
cuando se acerca el mundial en kerala el
ambiente es diferente
en las tres o cuatro semanas previas la
gente empieza a hacer este tipo de
carteles
para mostrar su apoyo a su equipo
comienzan a distribuir folletos sobre
los jugadores seleccionados de su equipo
[Música]
en 1998 Cuando era pequeño descubrí La
magia de zinedine Zidane Fue entonces
Cuando comenzó mi pasión por el fútbol
francés fui al centro de entrenamiento
de clair fortane estuve en el mundial de
Rusia estuve en la Eurocopa femenina en
Inglaterra Esta es la pasión por el
fútbol en kerala que a veces se producen
desmanes al comienzo del mundial de
Qatar los hinchas indios de Brasil y
Argentina se fueron a las manos los
hinchas brasileños hablaron mal de los
hinchas argentinos después de que
Argentina perdiera contra Arabia Saudita
de repente los hinchas argentinos se lo
tomaron en serio
y se enojaron mucho con los hinchas
brasileños
esto demuestra que esto no es solo un
juego para ellos Aunque
Qatar ha sido criticado por pagarles el
viaje a los hinchas a cambio de
comentarios positivos nuestro observador
asegura que él y los miembros del club
están allá por su cuenta
si escogen diez casas en kerala van a
encontrar al menos una persona
trabajando en un país del Consejo de
cooperación del Golfo
para las personas que vienen de la India
el alojamiento no es complicado en Qatar
porque tiene familiares vecinos y amigos
en
Gracias a todos nuestros observadores
por sus historias y si quieren también
informar a nuestra redacción de lo que
ocurre cerca de ustedes todos nuestros
contactos están en nuestra pantalla
esperamos sus fotos y videos para cubrir
juntos la actualidad internacional en
imágenes de aficionado Hasta pronto